Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, September 11th,
2017 what's going on? How are Ya?
How's it going? How's it going?
Um, more hurricanes, more hurricanes.
And this is the 70th anniversary of
the attacks on the World Trade Center.
Okay.
The Pentagon and then the one that went
down to Pennsylvania, you know, I mean,
Jesus Christ,
what is going on this week?
It's just all gloom and
frigging do you know,
I was sitting there watching the
news, the news with Nia, right?
And they're showing highlights of this.
Um, was it hurricane Irma is what it is.
Jim or safe was coming into fucking Miami.
Right?
And there's some fucking white dude
out there of course being like, well,
you know, it's no come down
real hard. They show like
five white people out there.
And Nia literally said to me, she
goes, what is wrong with white people?
Okay,
Eh, the lab. I was like, you
know, we, for the most part,
we grew up in called the sex. There's
no excitement. There's no drive.
Bys is no, uh, you know,
cops beat me up for no reason. Generally
speaking, you know, it's gonna hey,
knock it off over there. Straight
up. I know your father. You know,
it's Kinda like that.
So I guess, you know,
a hurricane comes around you where you
need a story. Shit, you need a story.
I have no idea why I came up with a hacky
eighties joke though about fucking the
hurricanes. It's, it's, it's,
why don't they have all the
people's Dan with a report?
Because the report has never died.
They're always standing in the fucking
middle of the shit. I don't know how,
I don't know how these news agencies
know exactly where to fucking stand,
but somehow they stand just enough in
the shit. I don't buy it. I don't buy it.
Um,
she has one of them died yet,
you know,
out of fuck. I mean, how the
fuck did that, you know, Jesus
bells spit it out. Sorry.
I flew today. Once I fall, I'm already
dumb. But once I fly it just, you know,
breathing that fucking
pressurized air up there. Um,
I mean, it's fucking inevitable. If you
stand out inside in a fucking hurricane,
someone's going to fall on top of it.
It's bad enough.
Like I love when they sit there and they
tell these people, you need to evacuate.
You got to get out of the, and it's
like, and go where? To my summer home.
Don't you remember the fucking bags left
half this country upside down in their
fucking house.
It's fucking unreal.
I don't understand like where these
people are supposed to go. Like where,
where do they go?
Everybody just goes north and sits
in a fucking waffle house for three,
four days. All the hotels get bought up.
And if you don't have money, what do you,
what? What are you supposed to do? Um,
anyways, at least it was knocked
down to a, to a category three men.
I read some fucking, you know,
it's some horrible shit about, uh,
Houston that's still going on now is
all mold and it's all in here. You know,
you don't need to listen to this.
You see it all fucking day.
This is all just gloom and doom,
all fucking misery here. So, um,
why don't I go to something positive?
I actually a friend of the podcast,
one of the great traumas of all time,
Steven Atla, uh, he sent me this thing.
He's got a, uh, they're doing
something for Ronnie James Dio. Um,
on October 6th,
it's 6:30 PM bull for Ronnie
Celebrity. Uh, Christ,
my eyes are going celebrity
bowling tournament. All right.
Oh fuck. I'm not going to be able to
read this. I can't. Okay, here we go. Oh.
Gotta love that. You can enlarge. Wish
I could do this to the world, man.
I have to get glasses. Why won't I just
give into the fact that I need glasses?
All right. October six, 2017,
6:30 PM celebrity bowling tournament.
Both for Ronnie.
Oh, for God's sake. Steven,
where's it going to be at?
Oh, it pins bowling center.
One, two, six five five
Ventura Boulevard, studio city,
California nine one six
oh four go down there.
It's for a great cause and a, you
know, have you self a white Russian,
you know, and tell Donnie
to shut the fuck up. Okay.
And it'd be down there for a
great cause. Alrighty. They go,
I'll have put up a link.
I'm going to post the whole a
flyer on the Monday morning.
Thingamajig there's another guy got
the TV on there and I'm on my Twitter
account.
There's a guy standing out there,
Jesus Christ standing out
there in the fucking rain.
Like the video al Roker is out there.
Okay.
How many hurricanes is that poor bastard
stood down and now it's going up to
Tampa and then it looks like it's going
to go right over the Florida gators
football stadium
somehow die around fucking Macon,
Georgia. And is that what they
said? Is that the trajectory?
I don't know what. Um, anyways, um,
so I was in a miss shippy
flew into fucking miss share
pay on Thursday night and
I missed the entire New
England patriots game.
And from what I've heard as a patriots
fan was probably better to just landed,
find out that they got the
shit kicked out of them.
Really just kind of in the
fourth quarter though. I mean,
it was kind of a shootout with no
fucking defense as far as I could tell.
The chiefs are all excited doing fucking
cartwheels cause they let up fucking 27
points. I don't know what
they're so fucking excited about,
but I will tell you as a patriots fan,
I'm pretty fucking happy.
Now I'm going to tell you
why I want to tell you why,
because I don't like the fucking worst
thing ever is when before you even start
the season, those fucking
hacks on this sports shows go.
You know they talk about
your team like they go right?
They start doing that shit. So before
the fucking season, our restarts,
you already got that
fucking monkey on your back.
Every fucking fat Douche who never got
picked in gym class coming in with his
fucking loafers and his
sweaters in India locker room,
just trying to rip the team apart
and just adding just distraction.
So right out of the gate we fucking lose.
All of that is gone.
And then immediately they go,
oh wait a minute, wait a minute.
Remember when you say in Tom Brady is
the after his last game was the greatest
without a doubt of all time.
Now with the exact same people one
fucking game later saying he's too old.
So I'm loving that. I'm loving
all of that. What would you know,
I would actually love if
we lost next week too,
but then they would have all this, you
know what's cause a toddler hit the panic,
blah blah blah. You'd have to
deal with that. So I'm hoping,
you know they were in the next three,
four they lose another one,
four and two and then they're five
just nobody's paying attention. No,
they treat us like the Indianapolis
Colts man when they were 13 and oh and
nobody said Shit for
whatever fucking reason,
which is really a reoccurring
thing with the Indianapolis Colts.
No matter what they do.
Hearing aids in the fucking helmets,
fucking pumping crowd noise in tank
and the final third of a season to get
Andrew luck steel and the
Patriots' offense fucking
being on the rules committee,
changing the rules of passing and
on and on and fucking on. Right.
Go on 13 and oh,
nobody's saying shit.
Oh they're just a bunch
of country boys out there.
We won't pay attention to them.
I love it. I love that we, uh,
I mean I hate our fucking defense,
but I haven't liked our defense
since we won our first three. Um,
I think ever since then we've
always been like a, you know,
well we're going to score,
you already going to score
35, we're going to score 38.
I always just, I just Kinda feel like
we've been like that for too long.
And occasionally we've broadened,
we brought in a shutdown
corner like a Revus um,
oh they take whatever the fuck his name
was who was here for like a year or two.
He was fucking great. But then all
of a sudden they're like, yeah,
okay now I want to get paid.
They like, yeah, Nah, Nah.
So, um, anyways, yeah. So I just,
I watched a little bit of the highlights.
I mean
when you give up an 85 yard
touchdown in your corner,
like fucking lets the guy go by him cause
he thinks that he's got help over the
top and the guy just isn't there.
I mean,
I really don't think that's the chiefs
kicking our ass as much as that's
mmm.
Just horrible defense.
You know what I mean?
I would say though that that guy
running for like 6,000 yards against us,
it's definitely a concern.
But you know,
what are we supposed to win it
every fucking year? You know?
I'm all right with it. I love it. I
love it. So there we go. So now what?
Now what we go 11 and five.
They'll fix it, but I don't know.
You know,
we don't,
we always fucking have guys and then they
make the pro bowl and then they asked
for more money. Then we let him go and
then we got to build it back up again.
So we'll see. It is definitely towards
the end of Tom Brady's career. You know,
I don't know how it could
have gone any fucking better.
MMM.
You know, what are you going
to tell me what the you do?
You know why so many people
out about that? Aside
from the fact that they hate the
patriots, it's, that's how people,
that's how most people live their lives.
You know,
they take one loss and
they just pack it in.
Oh,
and I'm including a lot of
patriots fans, you know, those ag,
but she can never listen
to those sports shows.
Cause even like the people who call in,
you know,
they always use words like concerned,
Oh dre, right now I'm really concerned
about our past DeepBench on dirt Jones
are you, what are you concerned
about as if you're like, you're,
you're a part of the coaching
staff and if it doesn't work,
you're going to get fired.
You're gonna have to put your
house up for sale and reload,
relocate your kids once again.
What exactly are you concerned about?
Um, but congratulations to
the chiefs. I've actually,
I've always liked the chiefs.
Um, I used to always watch the Superbowl
highlights and that one with tanks,
tramp, you know, 64 talks, power trap. It
was always like the one of the great ones.
She's just sitting there
laughing his fucking balls off.
And everybody loved that back then.
But now if they had that audio,
he'd have to issue an apology to the
Minnesota Vikings and bud grant in the
family and all that
bullshit. But um, so anyways,
I was flying back from Alabama and uh,
so the only football games I was
able to catch, I watched the uh,
Green Bay Seattle game, which I
know Seattle fans, hey, cause they,
they definitely seem like they were
getting the short end of the stick.
Certainly on that phantom punching
a injection, which I didn't see.
I just saw the replay of it. Of course
it happened on a fucking pick six.
Always fun to watch Pete Carroll
loop blow a fucking gasket.
But that guy is a great coach and that's,
that's a great defense.
You know what I mean? The fucking legion
to do, you know, legion of boom, sorry,
boom.
Right in your ass with the steroids.
Okay.
Fuck all you guys. If you're going to
bring up every fucking God damn time,
Jesus Christ, we bend a card in fucking
New England. I'm fucking trashed.
And everybody,
I am doing research on all your fucking
teams and I'm going to do what you guys
do every fucking time. You give me
shit about my, I'm fucking fine.
I'm going to fucking look in
the corners of your franchise.
Jesus Christ's like 30% of
that fucking team tested pause,
defense tested positive for fucking
steroids and this still just talking about
how great they are.
Unbelievable.
That's another colts won that gout caught
the fucking allegedly deflated ball,
which was never fucking proven.
MMM.
It's never fucking proven yet.
Tom Still got fucking suspended.
Everybody's basically paying the price
for the under suspension of Ray Rice.
I think when they go into Roger Goodell,
um,
how site would see that the
Patriots lost after the, uh,
those barstool guys had that hilarious t
shirt to him, just like a fucking clown.
Is there anything better than just
call and say he's a fucking clown?
All your accomplishments just go right
out the window. They're fucking guy.
Roger Goodell makes $30 million a year,
$30 million a year,
and you can catch a walk into his car
and you're going to tell you you're a
fucking clown. I'm telling you, as much
as he has $30 million puppy, seven,
16, after taxes, it bugs him.
He's going to be thinking about it
when he's drinking his little donkeys,
coffee in the morning. Fuck is that
guy to call me clown talking himself.
You know, when he's putting his suit on
and he's got the jacket, tie and shirt,
he looks like one of those guys.
He gets everything on.
He puts the pants on last Clooney
already has his shoes on with the fucking
socks in the sock.
Garters you're going and talking to
himself as he's adjusting the nut in the
fucking, the night right there and
then in the mirror. Um, so anyways,
so I watched that game
and uh, the defenses, uh,
look to obviously great and those
fucking games. And uh, and now I got the,
I got the cowboys and giants
in the background. Um,
I did watch the Moto GP race. I
just watched the uh, the big boys.
I didn't get to watch a moto GP,
three or two,
but what a fucking race about mark mark
has just saying, you know, Davinci also,
it's just like, hey man, I'm going to
take, I'm going to take the bucket points.
Mark Marquez is like,
fuck that. Fuck that.
I'm going for the victory for you
guys at all. Watch motorcycle racing.
It was raining out and they still race.
They don't quite go as fast,
but they were going like over 150 miles
an hour in the fucking rain on each
other's asses. And this guy, what the
fuck was his name? He started the race.
He fucking shot right up
the side in the first place.
What the Fuck is be able to pee? I can't,
I don't know. I'm new to this sport.
I don't know all their names.
So anyways, now it did.
It was that guy a bill.
Why don't you just look this shit up so
he can tighten? You know what happened?
He just can't remember the fucking names.
What was the guy's name? Larry Legend.
Is that the guy who fucking shut up
and first before he fucking wiped out,
there's more goddamn
accidents today or yesterday,
I should say when they were
racing. And uh, anyways,
everything that Formula
One needs moto GP has,
it was a race right down to the end. And
fucking Mark Marquez said, fuck this,
I'm going for the points.
Because if he got the 25,
he was going to be tied with Da.
Oh.
So he passed them on the fucking last
lap or second to last lap and then held
them off. Um, you know, there was
some film Nicholson Shit, you know,
I'm not going to fucking, you know, just
try and get back out on the fairway.
I'm going to try to put it in the hall,
then I'm going to four point and
walk away with sweaty tits. I mean,
that's what this man did,
but basically on a motorcycle.
So that was very enjoyable.
Uh, but let's get down.
Let's talk about going down south now
that the Patriot season is evidently over
and Tom Brady is a over
the hill. Um, you know,
the Atlanta Falcons won today
in the New England patriots.
Lost the exact opposite thing
that happened the last time. Um,
so there you go. I don't know what that
means. I'm sure Atlanta Falcon fans,
if they could switch, you
know, the results with the
Patriots, I think they would,
you know, but evidently the fucking
football sky is falling. Um,
you know what I fucking
hate about fantasy football?
That is literally taken over like um,
they used to have like in the
sports pages, he used to just have,
they would have like the leaders,
it was sunny.
It was really easy to find the leaders.
You could collect football cards and shit.
I used to know so much
more about the game.
I don't know anybody's
fucking name anymore.
Anytime you go to any sort of website
where they have like fantasy, they the,
when you want to look at stats,
it's all this fantasy football shit.
Get this guy on your team.
Peyton Manning's fucking
advertising that stuff.
Okay.
I Dunno. Should I just give in,
should it just give, I don't want it.
I don't want to do that shit.
I don't want to have somebody
on a team that I actually,
I don't really hate any
other team in the NFL.
Do I hit anything I hate
gym or say that's it.
That's the only person I don't like.
You know,
there's certain people that act like
fucking idiots in the league that I don't
particularly care for, but that
I don't hate the team. You know?
Here's another classic.
The cowboys are probably going to beat
the giants cause this is what the cowboys
and giants to the cowboys win in
the beginning part of the year.
And then the giants always
fucking losing in the end.
They come back around and they do
the same thing down in New York.
So time to move on from Ely,
he only steps up in every fucking big
moment in January his entire career.
I think it's time to get rid of him
because he fucked up in September.
Um,
yeah.
You know, I didn't even want
me to look this shit up.
Did that as Zq Elliot
guy play seems to me.
What's weird is they threw out
his case in the real world.
Yeah.
But it's like in the NFL,
you need less burden of proof.
Okay.
Elliot cowboys,
is that his fucking name?
Uh,
Elliot cowboys to play.
Is he playing judge grants?
Temporary restraining order requests
for Dallas cowboys running back probably
from that cycle. What would the
person of seeming like a psycho.
Okay. Is He, cause he goes,
I'll, it really makes you,
I've been out of the loop.
All right, so he played,
that's good. That's good.
Cause the clown was going to over suspend
them. The ALGA, that's the NFL is back.
And so at the 15 reasons
it's a complete disaster.
Hey, y'all bought those Los Angeles Rams
coming back wearing the lumbar Lundy.
Fucking blue and white.
The fearsome foursome.
Merlin Olsen. Rosey Greer. Was it
Lamar Lundy? I always forget him.
And then uh, what's his face there?
Ah, I can never name all four of them.
I always end up forgetting one.
I always remember Merlin Olsen
Rosey Greer out Jesus Christ.
The coolest one of them are Deacon
Jones and it was at Lamar, Lamar,
Lamar,
Lamar Lundy.
Is this even a podcast? Is this, you guys
listen to me fucking yeah, there you go.
Right. Lamar Lundy, was he a stealer
or was he a Ram? He was a Ram Lamar.
Lauren Graham's fearsome. I right. I got
it. All right. So anyways, let's get,
let's, let's, I'm not watching TV anymore.
Now I'm focused.
Yeah.
Now I'm focused. Oh,
is Eli driving him in?
What's he got his second and eight,
eight oh nine to go in the third quarter.
Eli calling a fucking
audible over the metal,
foreign affairs down,
moving the ball.
Cowboys fans are all going to be fucked
saying you need to fucking bench fucking
quarterback and bring back Roger
Stolle back. Um, so we did the, uh,
the Horseshoe Casino in Mississippi.
I had so much fucking fun doing that.
MMM.
Although it was just a part of the south
man that was just deep, deep, deep,
deep south, deep south.
Hang a fucking right.
Don't stop.
And Alabama keep going.
Stop right before you get
the fucking wheezing. Know.
And um, it was just, I dunno,
the pace of the people down there was
driving me fucking nuts. You know,
I ordered room service twice.
I kept ordering water and they
just wouldn't bring it up to me.
So the second time I said,
did you, where's the glutton?
Is there a glass of water?
And she's like, well, now I'm try.
Yeah.
And I'm like, and, and
that's what's on the tray.
It's just fucking walks out.
There's no, Oh, I'm sorry.
I'll go get you some.
It's like it wasn't on the tray.
So then I go to use it like
nothing fucking worked.
I go to use the fucking irony board.
The ironing board was fucked up.
I was trying to make it stand up.
It wouldn't stand up.
I had to bend the piece back.
It wouldn't.
And then I finally just had a fucking
meltdown and I'm admitting this to the
casino. I jumped up and down on it
and then I pulled the shark nose back.
I felt bad afterwards and I tried to
bend it back, but it's all fucked up.
If you wonder why it's fucked up, I
finished it off. It was already fucked up.
So if you want to send me
a bill, I apologize. Um,
and then the next day meet Dean and Bart.
Nick drove over and to
Tuscaloosa to go on.
We went to go see Alabama
versus Fresno state. Uh,
we had a great fucking time.
Um, we met some people there,
some friends of mine and a,
they hooked us up. We were,
and I think this fucking
skybox no sunburn. You know,
it was a cupcake game. Who's kidding? Who
Against Fresno state. It was a day game.
It's like I went,
but I have to go back there again.
I want to go there and night game
when they play like Texas a and M,
Mississippi or fucking,
you know,
anybody like Lsu or some shit like that.
I want to go back for that and I want to
sit in the fucking crowd the next time.
Um, this was like, it was too nice.
It was awesome. I had a great time,
but it was like a, I didn't, I didn't
get to feel the crowd a little bit,
which was perfect because I had a
show that night, so I didn't drink.
I'm still not drinking and I didn't
get a sunburn. So it worked out for me,
but I feel like I kind of
went to a preseason game. Um,
so we're walking out of
there and fucking Joe Barton.
It's somehow found the one
Russian guy in Alabama.
Then shit escalated quickly.
Okay.
You know, bardic walks up
to the guy, the guy, uh,
I don't know how they got
into a conversation. The
Guy said he was, somehow,
he said he, he always heard his talk
and he mentioned, said something to us,
we're waiting for the elevator.
And the guy said that he was Russian,
so bar next to a huge penguins
fan. And he goes, yeah,
oh, he's that guy. You're a
Russian. He goes, hey, you know,
you'd say Gino Mulkin Malkin right? Hey,
you're like Malcolm. The guy's like, yeah,
Nah, Nah. He's like, I like go.
He's like, I let go vet skit.
You like a back shit. And then he gets
right in the guy's face and he goes,
zero cops, zero cops. He's
like a vege kidney goes
doing the choking thing.
Right.
Joe had had a couple of SAS
Barilla's who's kidding who, right?
So they fucking start going
back and forth. And the e
Joe keeps giving him shit.
The guy's going, oh, come
on man. It's a team game.
Cops. And how can you
like Xero Cups? Xero cuff.
It keeps it active.
The guy's choking on a fucking
Dick in the Russian guys get mad.
Joe's fucking around.
He's not seeing it.
And the fucking elevator can not come
fast enough because it looks like it's
going to escalate into a fight,
which, you know, Joe Barton,
nick and this Russian guy was actually
taller than Joe, but he was skinnier.
But you know, you sell so Russian, you
know what I mean? So you know, you know,
it's fucking people. They be, they be,
they fucking bitch slapped Hitler
all the way back to fucking Berlin.
You know, let people out
of prisons and say, Hey,
remember we throw you in there for,
why don't you come out and go do
that to people who look like this?
And that's what they did. Half of
them weren't bare feet. I mean,
I know it's a legend at this point, but
it's just, it's pretty much fucking true.
So now I'm concerned because
they're both Joe's like whatever,
six for this guy's like six, five. And
I kept going, Joe, hey man. Hey Joe,
take it easy.
Go ahead guys.
That
he just kept doing it and
then he's laughing at the guy
and I don't know what, he
just wasn't seeing the guy
getting mad. So the guy goes,
hey, why don't we go around the
corner? And Joe's like, Hey,
let's go around the corner and they
walk around the corner. I'm like,
are they going to go fight?
And then there was this awkward little
moment between him and me and dean is
stone sober? Like what the fuck? So
finally I just go to my buddy goes,
there's some stairs we can take because
the elevator was taking forever.
And he goes, uh, yeah. He go,
yeah, we can take the stairs.
So we go to take the stairs
and we're going to walk out.
And the Russians guys like
I were to take the status to
now they're walking down the stairs and
it's just like, I couldn't separate them.
I couldn't get them separated. And, uh,
I dunno what happened by the end of it.
They were,
they were like best of friends ready
to go drink some fucking vodka. Um,
we actually left the game,
uh,
halfway through the fourth quarter
because we had to go do our show,
but we wanted to go around
and get a picture in front
of the bear Bryant Statue.
And uh, we actually got one in
front of the Nick Saban one.
There's one other guy that nobody,
everybody always forgets he's
only won one championship,
but it was pretty fucking amazing to uh,
to go there. I'm telling you, if you,
if you get a fucking chance, man,
everybody wants to go to the ballparks.
All the baseball parks,
they go to a fucking Lambeau
field and that type of shit,
which I understand, but you know, all you
guys who live in pro football cities in,
in, you know, New York,
Chicago, all that pro shit.
Boston don't sleep on going a big time.
College football man.
I'm telling you sec, big 10, you got
to go to the University of Michigan.
You got to go to horseshoe and our house
stay. You got to go to one of them.
You just have to experience
100,000 fucking people going
absolutely fucking nuts.
Pick a good rivalry game. Go on
fucking stubhub, pay through the nose,
go out there and get fucking hammered.
Go to the game and then please tell me
what you see in the NFL because I don't
think it,
the NFL can near nearly touches
excitement.
Although having said that,
how great is it that it's fucking
football season and this is what always
happened. Football season goes by
like the summer, you know what I mean?
Like every year in the summer, I'm
okay, it's May, we're going into May.
I'm really gonna pay attention and
try to enjoy and remember like, hey,
it's this summer. We're in the
summer. Let's fucking enjoy this shit.
I still feel that way.
Even though I live out in la where it's
summer all the fucking time, right? Um,
and every, every fucking year old
son, it's just like September, right?
And football seasons to same
thing. You're like, oh my God,
fucking football season.
It's fucking great.
Then all of a sudden it's
like it's the playoffs.
And you're so focused on the playoffs
playoffs that all of a sudden like
it's that week between the championship
game in the Super Bowl and you're like,
what the fuck happened?
You so busy putting money on the games
and betting on the fucking games.
You don't realize not only is
there only one, two teams left,
there's only one game left
and then then we're fucked.
Then we'll fuck too. Then the panic
starts to set and then you think,
well at least I got march madness,
right.
At least it got march madness and then
I got the the hockey and the basketball
playoffs and then there's just a,
it's just, you know what it really is.
It's just July.
It's that one panic of
July and into August.
The dog days of baseball
that you have to fucking deal with. That's
how I ended up getting into fucking,
I think Formula One and all
that shit just to cover that.
Then I totally got into it.
I don't know.
I feel like I've been talking in
circles for like fucking 25 minutes.
What is this? How many?
How many awful minutes?
This has been 26 see that comedian
long enough. You can, you can,
you could sense time.
I had this feeling that had been
bombing for 26 fucking minutes.
So a congratulations to everybody's team
who won this week cleaning the chiefs,
not a cunt and a everybody laws day.
It's only feed them.
Yeah,
it's just one week fucking relax.
25 days and no booze.
25 days of knows boobs. I'll tell
you how well I'm doing with no boots.
When I went out,
I went to the duty free and I saw
that Macallan McCallum rare cask
black, which I had never
heard of. And I'm like,
I am fucking buying that when I get,
when I come back off the plane
and when I got off the plane I,
you know,
I think I flew delta out
United on the way back.
So it wasn't there but I was
going to buy it. You know,
I'm sitting there talking to myself like,
am I done?
Like I was actually
thinking on the plane today,
like I might be done for good.
And then I came home and I ordered
these whiskey glasses and I'm like,
well that's not a good sign. Like if
you just say, I'm done with heroin.
And then you go to Amazon or you
go to like syringe.net, you know,
and you just order a bunch of fucking
drug paraphernalia,
I guess as long as you don't buy the
drugs. Right. I just gay officer,
I collect crack pipes.
Okay.
Can I ask them?
Can I have my license back please?
You're not gonna find
any residue in there.
Um, so anyway, I was actually
thinking on the plane. I'm like,
am I, what if I just next
year I turned 50 right?
And I'm just done with the booze and
then I just become like this yoga
[inaudible] guy. I just go
stink. Right? Gordon Sumner,
I become that fucking guy.
You know,
I look good for my age.
If I actually fucking did that through
my fifties I would look fucking
unbelievable.
It's 64 60 year old,
you know?
And you figured by then you know how
good tanning beds are going to be,
how good the hair plugs are going to be,
you know,
and I bet I'll be microchipped by then,
which I can also have
like the added Viagara uh,
option to it.
You know what I mean?
I think I can stay in the game for
another 10 years after that. I don't know.
What do you guys think? Have you
guys thought about the future? You,
the microchipped you full
head of hair and ABS.
Um, all right, let me read
some advertising you. Oh,
speaking of fantasy football,
you know,
is the best thing about fantasy football
rather than sitting around fucking
giving a hand job.
Do you divorce buddy and your own fucking
living room during your stupid draft?
Why don't you go to draft kings and
try to make some money so you can least
afford some lotion a week.
One is in the books,
but it's not too late to get closer to
the game you love with draft kings one
week fantasy football
because of this site, right?
Their draft kinks.
This Sunday draft kings is hosting a
$100,000 pick 'em contest that is totally
free to enter. Pick them is the
newest way to play one week.
Fantasy drafting your
team is faster than ever.
Draft Kings has organized
players into eight tiers.
All you have to do is select one
player from each tier through.
This is like doing an 18 tease.
Now if you pick it perfectly,
you're telling me you win $1 billion.
That's what they were saying.
Choose between public
contests with big cash prizes,
a prime bit content as well. You can
compete against the group. You know,
draft chains also has a beginner and
casual contest where you'll play against
people of similar skill level.
Everybody wants to go home with a ribbon.
The best part is you get draft.
You get to draft a new team each week
without any commitment, bitch, it's over.
So get to draft kings.com now and use
Promo Code Berta play and draftking draft
kings free contest with $100,000
in total prizes this Sunday.
Use My Promo Code Burp you are
to play for free this Sunday.
That's Promo Code burr@draftkings.com
eligibility restrictions apply.
See draftkings.com for details.
People try to have fun with that.
Okay?
Don't fucking put your whole
mortgage on it. All right. Okay.
Here we go. Where am I going? Where am I
going? Frame bridge, everybody. Oh, Jesus.
Frame Bridge. You know what's
frame bridges? Well, Jesus Christ,
it's easiest way to custom frame your
favorite art and photos without ever
leaving your house.
You Fat.
Fuck with their simple online
ordering project process.
You can order a fully customized
customized piece in minutes.
Here's how it works. Yeah, you can
fully customize your Dick Pics.
Somebody should do one of the only
those school pictures, whether it's,
whether it's,
it's the double shot where
it's you looking straight
ahead and then you look it
up in the air. You got to do a
Dick kicked version of that. Um,
here's how it works.
Go to Frame bridge.com upload your photos
from your computer or directly from
your Instagram feed lady.
Or if you have a physical item,
they'll provide secure prepaid packaging
so you can mail it in for free.
Preview your photos
online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get a free
help from their talented designers.
The expert team at frame
bridge will customer what?
Custom frame your item in days,
not weeks or months and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang the best part instead of
hundreds, you'd pay at a framing store.
Their prices start at just
$39 all shipping is free.
Plus my listeners will get 15%
off their first order frame.
bridge.com when they use my code.
Burr frame bridge even offers a
happiness guaranteed. Are you happy?
If for any reason you aren't
100% satisfied with the order,
they'll make it right. Give your personal
experience using frame bridge.com oh,
I'll give it to you.
Um, I've never used it.
I keep saying I'm going to use it.
I keep taking pictures,
uploading them to my computers and then
sticking them on the hard drives and
ended up in the back of my closet and
then I sit there and wonder what the fuck
happened to him. And I wished
that I, I got some of them framed.
So frame bridge, you're like the,
you're the website that got away.
You know that chick. I should have said
hello to, you know, taking an at bat.
I'm the site is easy. The site, the ease
of order and half. Shut up man. Okay,
get ready to get started today.
Framing your photos or art.
Go to frame bridge.com and use
the Promo Code [inaudible].
You'll save an additional
15% off your first order.
Just go to [inaudible] dot
com Promo Code burr framing,
[inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Pat. All
right, last lastly, but not leastly.
Oh Jesus Christ. Would you look who
SPEC would you look? Who's back?
Ladies and gentlemen?
stamps.com the original.
I think these are the first people
ever advertised on my podcast.
Stamps saved you time and money,
which she can use to create cause if
you didn't use the stampede up to get in
your car and fucking deliver
it yourself. Right? Stamps,
saving time and money which you
can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer and
Perretta and the fucking mailman comes
and picks it up. Avoid the hassle, man.
I'm going to the post office and mail
everything from postcards to envelopes to
packages, domestic or
international. No drugs.
Create your stamps account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments. Click
print mail in. You're done.
Unlike the post office
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or
packages at your own convenience.
24 seven buy and print official US
postage for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your own computer
and printer stamps.com makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale.
It automatically calculates the exact
postage stamps.com we'll even help you
decide the best class of
mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage
meter for the last fucking time I use Dan.
Stop calm anytime I sent out my posters.
Anytime I sell posters
at the end of the show,
I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you and right now,
right this very many,
you too can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital
scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeofbirchstampsdotcomandabarstamps.com
never
go to the post office again.
All righty there.
That has done that has done so.
I'm actually toying with that idea.
You know,
no booze done,
done. I don't know if I can, I don't know.
I understand why alcoholics like they
take it one day at a time cause she cause
just sitting there like, I'm never
going to do this. Not just today.
I'm just not going to do it today.
Just not gonna do it today.
You know, sometimes you've
got to do it though, right?
You know
your wife's talking to you and you're
sitting there looking at her smiling and
nodding.
Okay.
She's thinking,
Oh I love what he looks at me that way
he still
loves me.
I can see it in his eye.
And you're actually thinking about
that bottle of booze that you bought.
How are you going to go out in the
garage like a fucking degenerate?
Sit some dirty chair. You
don't give a shit, right?
Pour that glass.
You set the bottle down.
It touches the floor.
You hear it echoing in your garage.
You know that garage that's yours,
right?
That garage that you made the decision,
you weren't going to be like these.
Most of these guys who let their
wives not only take over the house,
but also the garage, right? And they
just fill it up with all this shit.
You can't even get the fucking
car in their garage is yours.
He put up the DART board.
You get the Keg rater.
That sets you little fucking tree fort.
You know
mean. Who's kidding? You're
a guy. You're still a child.
Just because you can grow a beard
doesn't mean you're mature. All right.
What'd you look at all these stars
doing these fucking commercials now?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Can you leave something on the
bone for the struggling actor?
Can't you just do a fucking ad
over in Guam like you used to?
Um, anyways, well, well,
well Dre, I want to Redo my
fucking garage again. Oh God,
I gotta I gotta add something else in
there. I gotta add a fucking, you know,
now that I never had my truck in
there, you know, I put it in storage,
so I kind of flip flop and everything
like that with the new car and then the
old car. I haven't driven my truck in
like two weeks, man. I miss it. Uh,
I gotta do that Sunday. I got to have the
garage with the fucking room above it.
You just have to have it.
That's what it is, you know?
And then what'd you do?
You have a fucking prenuptial
agreement that if we get divorced,
I get the garage and the room above
it and you can not fucking evict me.
That will be mine and you will get
the fucking house. But you know,
something fucking,
they'll just people.
But I just still feel safe
with him being out there.
They'd cry their way into getting that to,
you know,
I swear to God,
I wonder if anybody,
like when a hurricane's coming in,
if they're in an unhappy marriage,
like what's going through their mind?
You just sitting there with your wife,
you know,
she doesn't know that you bought a boat.
They get tied to the back of the house,
a little fucking row boat. You know,
she can't see it.
You convince her to try to ride out the
storm and then when the water comes in
you like say you're later. Oh
Jesus, Bill. Um, all right,
let's get to the fucking questions
this week. I apologize. What do I,
you know what? I don't apologize. I don't
apologize for fucking making up shit.
I'm making up Shit, man. What the
fuck he want from me? All right, boo
lineups,
booze lineups.
Did I talk about everything I want to
talk about first before I get into this
shit? Let's see here.
Steven Adler. Ronnie James,
Alabama versus Fresno state.
Mississippi Horseshoe or ironing
board. Oh yeah. When I was waiting
for the fucking car to come around,
I was standing out in
front of the hotel going,
I'm never coming to this fucking
state again. I was so fucking,
everything was going so goddamn slow.
But you know,
once I got over my five
second temper Tantrum,
I realize that I actually
had a great time there.
So I'm going to come back
next time I'm coming back.
It's either when ole miss or
Mississippi state has a game.
I'm going to a fucking game
that and helped to play in
Alabama or some shit like
that. Um, Joe finds a
Russian, I talked about that.
No boots 25 days or Billy fucking red
velvet cakes was going to take a month
off. Now all of a sudden
he thinks he's the next.
He's the second comment is stink,
you know,
staying held onto their hair.
He was losing the roof and then all
of a sudden he started doing yoga.
He started standing on his fucking head
and all that blood went to the top of
his head, started feeding the
roots and that's what happened.
Maybe might not come back.
Fantasy football is taken over.
Trading cards and all that shit.
I talked about that.
Well I guess it's time to
get on the fucking with the,
uh, the booze lineups here.
All right. This guy's booze lineup.
Hey, Billy bollard shops. Uh,
I'm a listener from a
listener from the UK. I uh,
by the way, it's 16 to three. Well,
you guys already know this shit.
Dallas playing some good defense.
I'm a listener from the UK.
I managed to get to your
show in Manchester and it
was brilliant. Thank you.
That was nervous about that show.
You know,
all I knew it was this fucking soccer
hoodlums from the 80s. You know,
the fucking neo Nazis falling around
man United. That's all I knew.
I read among the thugs and to
me that was Manchester. Um,
he said I wanted to send you my team of
drinks, but I don't watch baseball. Oh,
you're batting lineup. Okay. I tried
when I was in New York to watch baseball,
but I found it boring. Same with
football. Fucking boring. Uh,
he means soccer here I guess cause he
says I only watched for that for the World
Cup.
I mainly watch rugby league.
You Watch set seven nation league where
if you come in last she get the wooden
spoon.
Um,
NFL for the Seahawks cricket and
I'm a big fan of effluent. Dude.
If you can sit through fucking cricket,
you can get through a baseball game.
I mean that's the same thing except
cricket last for fucking five days.
Um, I decided to send you my list
of drinks as the Formula One teams.
I don't really drink that many neat
spirits or whiskey. Soy included.
Everything else I drink when I
want to get pissed. All right.
Leading off he's gotten,
Mercedes is Mercedes Benz team for those.
You don't want you f one, they're like
the fucking cream of the crop. Uh,
we really should have batting cleanup,
but I get this,
you're going to do this more like,
you know how they rank football teams
the best to the worst. All right,
a IPA beers. Yeah. I'm one of those guys,
but I know piss people off talking
about it. My pole position. Drink.
Quite happy to drink these beers
all night. Drink iph all night.
Jesus Christ. It's like
drinking a Thanksgiving
dinner. Each pint is so fucking
I hate. There's so fucking I,
you know, every once in a while,
if I just want to have one beer,
but I know I'm going to drink 30,
I'll have an IPA because by the time
I'm done with it, I'm just like,
Jesus Christ had enough
and I put the fucking hops.
Good Lord. It's like overacting could bug
in your eyes out of your fucking head.
I get it.
Beer supposed to have hops as long as
you don't drink any of those stupid beers
that have those, those aggressive
for no reason. Names, you know,
angry fuck face. Kick your mother and
the cut beer whenever they lay him.
Angry Ale. All right. Is second
batter would be for the Ferrari team.
Jack Daniels Black label old number seven,
whatever you want to call it.
Uh, been around for these
all these years and it's,
and it is as popular as it's always been.
Usually drink it with the coke.
Rarely neat. Oh Jesus. This
guy's not even a AAA here.
Batting third,
red bull.
Mount Gay with mount gay a clips rum.
All right.
If you were in your twenties,
I forgive you for this lineup.
I've been drinking it with ginger
beer since these guys were he jaguar,
all the red box side, the red bull
team. I'm a fucking idiot. Some, sorry.
I thought you were drinking red bulls
in mount gay eclipse rum. I was like,
what the fuck? Oh, sorry.
I apologize. All right.
For Sindia team is there's a brown
liquor vodka. Never heard of that.
Usually with apple juice.
Do I give me honestly you drink like
a woman you see with apple juice and a
little umbrella in there and I saw this
spin around a couple of times and I like
fatness.
I'm new to good vodka like a few Brits.
I was drinking a paint stripper.
Vod paint Stryper vodka
and red bull from 17. Um,
all right. The Williams.
Stella up our toys logger.
It's okay.
William's team is to Stella are toast.
I don't know how to say half the shit.
The old dependable. I never heard of it,
but doesn't win many races anymore.
Still nothing beats turning up at a
mate's house with a crate of Stella for a
day of drinking.
Toro Rosso team would be sailor Jerry rum.
This guy's a rum drinker.
When I started drinking rum and move
to the red bull team not long after.
All right, Molly, she didn't mix
that with anything. The highest,
the American Formula One. Jack Daniel's
single barrel one for the Americans.
There you go. The only whiskey I really
drink. Neat. Good man. There's hope for,
you know that poor ass team a bitter,
uh,
the classic British British drink,
which is not served warm.
It's served at cellular cellar
temperature. I don't even,
what bitter is Mclaren Jaeger Meister?
Not as good as it used to be,
but I have some great
nights drinking this stuff.
How the fuck anybody drinks more than
one of those is beyond me. Uh, the,
the SABA team, I don't even know who that
is. Bringing up the rear. It's cider.
Yeah.
Not even close
to a go to drink, but I'm glad
it's there. I fucking hate cider.
A lot of the podcastsF is for family and
all the specialists come back to the UK
soon. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
I'll definitely be back there.
Thank you for your booze lineup.
Um,
there was actually a couple of
interesting things in there. Okay.
That's a brow vodka.
I never heard of that.
Yeah,
but you know, I'm going to do yoga
and pilates for the rest of my life.
I'm going to age like sting. Granted he
started doing that Shit in his thirties.
All right, number two. All right.
Uh,
um,
question number two or whatever
the fuck I'm doing this week.
A rhinestone stone ball bag. Billy, uh,
love the podcast and love when you rip
into the more on simply for being morons.
Keep it up.
That's why I trashed myself so much.
I wanted to throw down a booze lineup,
but for hockey. All right, here we go.
We're going for more booze line am I
feel like this is getting old people.
I'm going to read this last one that's
going to be it for the booze lineups and
every once in a while we'll do it. Uh,
we need some more overrated, underrated,
uh,
center.
The Cindy crabby position,
Miller genuine draft.
I hate that beer. God bless
you. Somebody's got to drink it.
You pay a little too much for him,
but he's your franchise player. See,
you have no choice.
Left wing is Weiser's black labels,
smooth dangles and sets everyone else up.
Right wing is Santiago
16 year Cuban run rum.
Foreign player.
Other teams are afraid to sign
that plays his ass off every night,
but take some stupid penalties, man.
Number One, Jack Daniel, safe, gritty,
defensive minded and,
and you didn't break the cap.
Hit Forum demand two cores
light never misses a game,
jumps up in the zone,
but on the wrong end of the odd man
rushes to often goalie is crown royal
hometown boy that gives you 65 starts
this season and always gives you a chance.
Bartok would love that lineup.
I don't know about Miller genuine draft,
but he'd love that you've
finished with crown royal. Uh,
thanks and go fuck yourself.
All right.
Okay,
now we're on, now we're onto
some fucking questions here. Uh,
all right. The fuck are
we, uh, Bill [inaudible].
What is this? This is more
fucking football. I can't do this.
There's too many boobs lists here.
What's this going to get?
Boring because it requires me to really
read out loud. I'm not good at all right.
Fingerprinting students.
What in the fuck is happening
to this world? Hey Billy Bo.
Baggins I'll try to keep this short.
I just started college
and in the dining halls,
they now only use fingerprint
scanners to let you in.
Cooking is not allowed in the dorms,
so if you want to eat,
you have to give them your fingerprints.
I'm not one of those.
I got shipped slash free tee shirt people.
But what else can I do?
You have thoughts would be appreciated.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Well,
millennials,
I think it's time you fucking rebel.
You got to rebel against something here.
Yeah,
I'll go to subway.
Okay.
Why do they need your fucking fingerprints
and what are they going to do with
them? Even if they're not
going to do anything with them,
they're going to hack into your system.
Somebody's going to hack into the
system that's so fucking nuts.
That is legit.
I honestly have to look up like how,
how are co,
how do people justify taking your fucking
fingerprints to give you a fucking
slice of pizza?
Okay.
How do colleges justify
taking students fingerprints?
I love all the mainstream
fucking pussy ass.
Fucking corporate media never talks about
this shit. They just sell people loud.
Did just such fall these fucking idiots
screaming about Trump and Hillary and
this is what they're doing to
citizens of this fucking country.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Can I refuse to have my child
fingerprinted at school?
Background of fingerprinting. I got to
uh, Jesus. I almost lied to you guys.
I got to read up on this. Like,
I'm actually going to do this.
Should schools fingerprint your kids?
Isn't that of, what is this for? Let
me guess. It's for our own protection.
Okay.
All they do is make gift bags for people
that know how to go on the Internet and
steal shit.
Here it is.
Here's the fucking social security
number with the fingerprints,
the home address, all the relatives
and all in a nice, neat, nice,
neat little fucking bag.
I,
I can't fucking believe that this,
these fucking jerk offs,
these fucking jerk offs. Anybody Watches
Fox and CNN is a fucking jerk off.
When was the last time they held the
feet of the fucking car instead of doing
all of this shit at the end, the fire.
When the fuck are they ever done that?
Okay.
If they ever really gone off
the pharmaceutical companies
for starting a heroin
epidemic and they ever really gone
after Monsanto for fucking with the food
supply.
Have they ever really gone after bankers
for what the fuck they were allowed to
get away with 10 fucking years ago?
Yeah.
Jesus fucking Christ.
You get one off colored fucking joke.
They cover that more than these fucking
insurance companies are probably gonna
fuck everybody over. Ah, now I'm upset.
Yeah.
You know what I would do, sir? I would
fucking somehow go out of my own pocket.
Then I would fucking eat down the street
for fucking cheap the best I could.
That's why you can still bring snacks.
You can't cook.
You can still have a fridge, right?
I need a bowl of fucking cereal.
I would eat a fucking
bowl of cereal three days,
three times a fucking day before
I'd get those fucking cunts.
You goddamn fingerprints.
First of all, you,
all you're going to do is
come out of college. You,
you're going to be all these student
loans and what sort of job is even to be
there? You've got to give
me a fingerprints to fuck
these people. Fuck up.
You know? I Dunno. You're not even
allowed to fucking protest anymore.
You'd have to go to a certain section.
You'd have to get a
fucking permit to protest.
Do I guarantee fucking t you?
I guarantee you the reason why they're
taking your fingerprints is an added
revenue stream and they're
going, they, you know, they're,
they're going to fucking
sell them to somebody else.
All of those fucking people that
take your fucking information.
How we getting weed seed safe. It's
secure, it isn't safe and secure.
What they've done now is they've made
it a lot easier for these people that go
in and steal shit rather than having
to having to break into you personally.
They just break into a company and
they get like a flu or whatever,
a couple thousand people
a whack.
And then what kills me is after
these cons, take your information,
their system gets hacked into and you can,
you sue them
for putting your shit up there.
Say it's fucking unreal.
Anyways, I just recently had, you know,
a TV network that I worked
for sent me a fucking letter.
She go in there and go read
it and say, uh, you know,
unfortunately someone broke
into our system and uh, the,
a lot of personal information
was x might've been exposed.
So all they're required to do after.
It's like,
why did you keep all that information?
We need to go back to paper
and file cabinets. People.
I'm telling you make these fucking
pieces of shit put on blue cat burglar
outfits have the flashlight in their mouth
is they try to pick the lock to go in.
I'm sorry, I really just lost my
shit there, but I feel like my,
I know even though I didn't have
all the information I needed to,
to make a logical argument,
I I feel like I am right.
I'm sniffing around something there.
All right. Alcoholics anonymous.
Hey Bill. I was in Aa for roughly two
years. If you're thinking about attending,
I would suggest you visit a
library and get the AA big book.
Sometimes they have a copy
available. I would read it. Okay.
Now you just asked me to do two things
that are really difficult for me. One,
going to a library and to finding a
book and then actually three reading it.
Um, what else you want
me to dunk a basketball?
You're really getting outside
the realm of what I do here. Uh,
then I would also read the
orange papers and online website,
which attempts to debunk
the AA philosophy,
attend a few meetings and get
a feel for it. But honestly,
I don't think you're an alcoholic
from listening to your podcast.
I just think you're a piss head. Uh,
you can put a cork in the bottle.
I hear you sometimes beating yourself up
when you've had three large pores. Oh,
Jesus. Relaxed. That's not
alcoholism. I love this guy. Uh,
sure.
You're probably not a good drinker,
but it's all on a spectrum and you seem
to be doing fine when you start drinking,
cleaning gel mixed with fruit
juice because it has alcohol in it.
Then we can talk.
I've heard it all in Aa and,
and you don't qualify for the club
in my humble opinion. Take it easy.
You're bald. Fuck. All right, well
thank you for the kind words, sir. Um,
no, but it's also, it's not good for you.
I can tell you it's not the level that
I was drinking was not good for you. Uh,
but I announced them think Aa is bad. If
it works for you, then I think it's good.
If it doesn't work for you,
I don't think you then have
to go out in deep bunk it.
What kind of a cut does that like alcohol
and non alcoholic anonymous has helped
so many fucking people.
Let me look at the orange papers.
Who fucks the asshole?
Who to say everybody just always
has to rain on somebody's parade.
Orange papers here.
I just realized something.
We might be fucking riding
out this hurricane down in
Florida listening to this
podcast. If you still have power, if you
get a generator and I just said rain.
Rain on your fucking parade. Sorry. Um,
where do the orange papers? Orange
papers. I spilled orange. Wrong.
I put two n's in there. I Dunno why
I said O r n a n g orange papers.
Aa.
Here we go.
Orange papers.
Recovering from recovery,
anti gay sites such as orange papers.
All right,
now this is just going to be another
website that just hijacked the whole
fucking thing so I can't get to it.
Where are the original orange papers?
Original. Original please,
please. Can I get the original?
I can't find it.
I cannot fucking find her. What
the fuck? Come on bed. Alright.
It just clicked on this page and I
see a big picture of a monkey leaving.
Aa staying sober. All right, here we go.
For the suffering alcoholic
and those unhappy in Aa.
Yeah.
All right. Let's see what
they pitch. Your body here
for the suffering alcoholic and those
unhappy and Aa alcoholics anonymous has
over 2 million participants globally.
That's it.
It is a friendly and welcoming
organization with many
caring, helpful members.
AAA offers companionship,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
If you think you have a drinking
problem and haven't tried Aa,
stop reading this essay and
go to a meeting. However,
a growing number of
options of slowly we can.
I want to fucking read all of this shit.
All right. I'll take your word for it.
Evidently
we get Eli stepping up in the pocket.
What's the score?
Yeah.
16 to three, seven minutes to
go. Did he just throw a pic?
Who knows?
Alright.
Wife working out with X.
Oh, Jesus. Fucking Christ.
If I saw that at the beginning of a
fucking porno, I'd be like, oh my God,
can we come up with a fucking
less cliched scenario?
Okay.
Oh, okay. Hey there, Billy red sack.
Love your podcast. Love F is for family.
Can't wait for season three. I wanted your
advice on something. Here's the story.
I got married about a year ago and me and
my lovely wife moved to La right after
the wedding because she had
a great job opportunity.
She had lived in La a few years ago prior
to meeting me and when she was living
here, she had a fling with some
douchey if private fitness trainer,
both of them viewed marriage as a stupid
concept and they made a pact that when
they'll get married to other people,
they'd meet up and fuck,
I don't believe a fucking word of this.
This is too stupid.
They made a pack.
When when they'll get
married to other people,
they'd meet up and fuck.
I mean,
it definitely sounds like
an la conversation in a gym.
I'll continue reading. Uh,
so as soon as she changed her relationship
status status to married on Facebook,
that guy sent her a bunch of messages,
which was sexual and pretty much offense.
Oh.
Offered to take her up on
the agreement and fuck.
She didn't respond,
but she did tell me about it,
but I didn't lose my shit in
remained calm in the last few weeks.
She told me she's looking for a way to
get in shape and she said that the Douche
she had offered her private workout
sessions in exchange for a help and his
business,
she's an accountant.
She said that because private workout
sessions are expensive and he's very good
at what he does. This is a great
opportunity that would save us some money.
She said she made it clear to him that
she's happily married and nothing is
going to happen,
and he understood completely.
She asked me if it bothers me and I
not wanting to look like the insecure,
jealous type. Oh my God, you fucking dude.
I'm telling you these fucking
women are in guys heads.
Yeah.
All of this bullshit that
you've seen on fucking TV.
All of these fucking women fucking
playing the victim all the time.
All of this fucking coverage of just what
guys do to women has now every fucking
guy has his balls in
his fucking back pocket.
And it's just like,
well,
I don't want to be the guy that fucking
makes you uncomfortable if she fucking
tolerate this from you,
you don't want to look into,
that's not being insecure, sir.
That's common fucking sense.
So he honestly,
honey,
I trust you.
I want what's best for you
and tried actually to do that.
My question is, do you think
she's trustworthy? Possible,
but that guy isn't. Hmm.
And that guy's just drawn her
in cause he wants to fucker.
Um, she does have a history
of cheating on her exes,
but so do I. We both been happily
married in our sex life is great,
but still the doubt and insecurity
about that. This issue exists.
Love to hear your take on this. Can't
wait for the new hour special. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself
buddy, buddy. Yeah, no, no,
no fucking way. No fucking
way. Work some extra hours,
you know,
I would actually be willing to believe
that she's gone over there thinking she's
not going to do anything,
but that guy's going to seducer.
That's what's going to happen. They
already banged. They're already, you know,
physically like,
you know,
yeah.
You know,
the boundaries are not going to be there.
And I'm telling you that that's not
a good situation and you're not in,
you're not insecure at all.
You know?
And so what if you are,
that's a legitimate,
that's a legitimate feeling,
that full fucking thing.
Let's let those stupid fucking tee shirts.
I saw this,
there's some woman was wearing this
fucking tee shirt that I told you about.
That one was back in the summertime.
It said something like,
yeah,
a real man is excited by a strong woman.
A boy is like whatever,
intimidated or something like that. It's
just some musical. Oh, I want to be,
I want to be considered a strong man.
I want a cookie.
Okay.
I was reading that rolling
stone where they had the, the,
the actress that was playing,
uh,
played wonder woman and I was all excited
to read the article in the first quote
that they had. They said, are you a
feminist? She goes, yes, I'm a feminist.
Everyone should be a feminist because
if you're not a feminist and you were
sexist,
right?
Yeah.
And I like bursting out
laughing thinking like, well,
it all depends on what your definition is.
Yeah.
That's what's funny about these Hollywood
people out here. I swear to God,
they sound just like the Fox News, right?
People, they're the exact, you know,
Zara is zero tolerance seal think
Savannah I do. If you do not,
then you are this,
um,
like there's no clear cut definition of
feminism any more than there is of like
what makes, you know that's real rock
music and in some ways always like Dutch,
not rock dishes. Rob Dad's bullshit.
It's the same thing with like family.
Like everyone was a feminist the
way my wife is, which, you know,
in all fairness, this actress
that played wonder woman could be,
I don't fucking know. But just to say
like that is just such a, I mean, granted,
it's a fucking interview.
They're trying to get people fucking
worked up to read the fucking thing.
Maybe it was taken out of context.
Maybe she said other shit,
but just the way that's presented, you
know, rolling stone is just fucking,
it's soft Boldo it's just fucking is
sufferable the way they handled Obama with
like kid gloves and if you,
if you're a fucking Republican,
they stick your head in the fire.
Now I'm not saying they shouldn't stick
these Republicans had in the fire.
I mean,
okay.
They're the fucking,
you know, the, the, the,
okay.
They're bought and paid for it.
That level. Right. Am I nuts?
And I also thought Obama was too,
judging by the $69 million with
the tour dates he has coming up,
given speeches to all
these fucking rich people.
Guy Just bought a $10 million
fucking house is fucking unreal.
And they don't say shit.
All they do is show him playing,
highlight and fucking going
kayaking and parasailing.
Cool.
I can't believe how cool he is.
MMM.
Anyways. By the way, rolling stone
is trumped the worst president ever.
I haven't noticed. He, it's not like you
up and fucking written it. It's just like,
I don't even read the fucking article.
It's like I understood your point of view.
The first 90 articles, there's so much
other shit you can be writing about.
You know what I mean?
Okay,
good fucking Lord.
Like my,
why can't you make fun of like extreme
liberals every once in a while?
Throw me a fucking curb ball,
something. Ah, Jesus Christ,
I fucking need to go buy some fucking
tampons here. I'm sorry. You know what,
when it happened,
you know what the funny stopped was the
fingerprint of these fucking poor kids,
these poor kids are going to college.
So getting it all in fucking debt.
All right.
And these colleges are acting like they've
adapted to how quickly the real world
is changing and I don't think they are.
And that's why these kids are coming out
and it's like they're coming out with
degrees in like fucking,
I don't know what the fucking
a churning butter essentially,
and then they can't find a fucking job.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't know. I remember like,
we always reading up about all
these fucking amazing musicians.
They would go to Berkeley and they would,
they would never complete the guys that
went out and seeing the guys that went
out and did shit. They never
finished. Like, they will like this,
this whole being here. I got
what I needed. Now I gotta
get the Fuck Outta here.
And, um, I'm not saying
drop out of college,
but I really feel like if that voice
is screaming in your head and you,
you fucking have some good ideas, why
take on the last year a debt, the last,
you know why?
Because your parents want you to,
um,
I dunno
what, because Bill Gates dropped out.
If you drop out, I'm just saying,
you know
what the fuck I ended up doing.
I didn't need to go to college and all
those fucking village student loan,
all a dead.
And I left and I immediately went down
to a comedy club and started doing shit
jokes.
Um,
anyways,
we got to end on something positive
here. Uh, please go to that. Steven.
Al The Ronnie James Think,
uh,
I'm going to post that the
bowl for Ronnie. Ronnie James.
What a fucking voice and what a great
guy too, man. I never met the guy,
but like ball his interviews, he couldn't
have been more down to earth. Uh,
once again, it's going to be at pins, P I
n Z bowling center, one, two, six, five,
five Ventura Boulevard. Uh, it's
gonna be a bunch of rock stars.
They're a bunch of comedians.
All Bolan raising money for a,
I don't even know what the, what is the
cause here? Why No, Ronnie died of cancer.
So I imagine it's that right?
Oh, Ronnie, Ronnie James Dio.
Stand up and shout a cancer fund.
There you go.
Stand up and shout. Right. Um,
so there's something positive for you and
I believe it's October 6th. All right.
I will be tweeting that out and I am
trying to get back onto Instagram.
I haven't posted on Instagram and forever.
I think I have to create an entirely new
account because I keep saying I forgot
my password.
Please email it to me.
And they haven't been able
or I haven't been able,
I can't find the fucking thing. Um, so
that's it. That's a podcast for this week.
Congratulations to everybody. One week,
one, congratulations all football fans.
That is football season. Uh, my favorite
fucking thing happened this weekend,
by the way,
when I was in the Alabama theater,
there was this fucking guy in the front
row and he had his middle age too.
We had his cell phone on it's
middle aged guy and I'm like, dude,
he recording the show. You
recording the show? And he
kind of was like, no. He goes,
he goes up looking at the scores
because it was Saturday night.
He wanted to see how the other SCC teams
were doing. And I go, well, what's what,
what are you watching?
He was watching the Georgia game.
I go with your Alabama to fuck.
Do give a shit about Georgia for.
He goes there in the SCC and I go,
they're not, I couldn't catch you.
They got that decent quarterback
though. I don't know. They're,
the crowd kind of dies down
and this guy in the back goes,
he says to the guy with the phone, he
just goes, excuse me sir, sir? He goes,
what'd he say? Oh, fuck it. I'm
going to put you the joke. Auburn,
Clemson, whoever the fuck
Auburn was playing, it was like,
I wasn't even there anymore. He
just asked for a score. Oh God.
What a fucking great setup or would
have been such a killer story if I could
have fucking remembered.
Okay.
Auburn score. What do we
got here? That's right.
They played Clemson. Yeah, he got,
excuse me sir. Auburn. Clemson.
That's all he had to say.
The guys just write it on his phone,
looking to give them the
fucking score. Um, I dunno.
It's a great fucking place. Don't
sleep on the south. All right.
If you really think about it, your
states just as racist. Okay, that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I don't know what else to tell y'all.
Check in on you on Thursday.
I hope. Um, you know,
my hope is, is a little damaged
in Florida as humanly possible,
and that's all he can fucking
hope for. And um, you know,
all you guys make it fun of people
driving electric cars. I don't know.
Now you know what the fuck
I drive gas combustion cars.
So I'm not fucking looking down on you,
but you know,
I don't know what the battery does in
the end when you drive the Tesla into the
fucking ocean. Can you recycle
the battery? I have no idea.
But I'll tell you what that guys doing
over there at that Tesla company.
I like it. I like it. I just wished the
car could look a little more meaner.
Looks great from the back. Looks
great from the side, the front.
I don't know what it is, just
can't quite get into it. But uh,
I know it's a fucking amazing car. But
then they asked you these fucking cool,
Huh?
The Lamborghini doors opening up a plus.
It's also a great way to win the
war in the Middle East. You know,
drive an electric car,
you ride a bicycle,
anything you do to use
less fucking fossil fuels,
fucks those people over over there and
they don't have money to funnel through
the mosques to give to the terrorist. And
there you go. And then all of a sudden,
oh, a Jimmy cracked corn is
out of fireworks, right? Oh,
I just saw the Middle East or
problem or the Middle East.
Prob not Middle Eastern. I don't have
problems with Middle Eastern people.
And this is why I don't hold office.
All right, go fuck yourselves people.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.